good morning Hank it's question Tuesday
on Wednesday today that I answer real
questions from real nerdfighters Hank
yesterday I sent out a tweet asking
nerdfighters if they have any questions
and they answered on mass do you have an
advice about nerdfighters starting in
first year in college I need advice
about college any advice for kids
starting college what's the best way to
get brain matter up my budget and stick
without leaving any DNA behind right so
most of them were about college having
both attended college and watch the
movie Animal House I feel like college
is one of my fields of expertise and so
far as I can tell there are five facets
of the collegiate experience academics
interpersonal relationships binge
drinking road trips and living on your
own all right so let's take these in
order number one academics I am going to
tell you a secret every year many many
stupid people graduate from college and
if they can do it so can you in fact I
would argue that it is not that
difficult to skate by at most colleges
that said it turns out to be a huge
mistake to ignore the academic facets of
college partly because the point of life
is to be able to engage as deeply as
possible with the miracle of human
consciousness and partly because there
will come a day when you are 35 years
old and you are writing a check every
single month to pay off your student
loans and it will be very helpful to you
if you feel like that money bought
something because my friends I am here
to tell you that you do not have to be a
college student to play beer pong so
study and the only other piece of
academic advice I'd give us to study
broadly I think it's really valuable to
take classes in lots of different
departments because you will be
surprised how the classes you don't
think you're interested in end up
shaping your life for example although
I'm not a science a person I took
several biology classes in college
including one called aids Ebola and
emerging viruses and it is as a direct
result of that class that today I am a
hypochondriac
number two interpersonal relationships
so most people when they start college
they're pretty worried about making
friends so here's some advice first be
nice to everyone also just be calm like
I don't know if this is true for anyone
else but when I get into social
situations where I feel uncomfortable I
can be a little bit like whoa hello
hello I'm John Rina be
I want to be friends I want to be
friends I can't hide it I can't matter
oh my god I want to be friends with you
so bad and that's scary for people a
couple other things never refer to
kissing a scoring never refer to the
ladies as the ladies and try not to pee
or throw up on anyone else or their
belongings I realize that's pretty base
level advice for those of us who are
potty trained but you would be
astonished how many people have
difficulty following that advice during
college which brings me to binge
drinking sometimes it seems like there's
only two kinds of college students these
days those who binge drink with alarming
frequency and those who define
themselves primarily in opposition to
that binge drinking I would submit that
neither of these worldviews is
particularly attractive I mean no one
likes holier-than-thou judgemental is
but on the other hand no one likes to be
vomited upon that's not true John well
it should be but let me encourage all
college students to embrace identities
that don't involve alcohol like just
join some clubs or something there are
so many clubs in college that's
something else I would say join clubs
but not just one Club people who belong
to just one club are super annoying cuz
they'll never shut up about their one
club like it's the only Club that
matters like the only place that needs
to be free is Tibet I love you to bed
it's nothing personal I just also a
Burma fourth road trips take them and
lastly living on your own except not
really because you don't have to clean
the toilets I'm not gonna tell you that
life in college is easy or give you any
of the lies about how it'll be the best
years of your life which it won't unless
you have a terrible terrible life but
the great thing about college is that it
creates this weird in-between space
where you're no longer a child but you
also don't have to do a lot of the
annoying things about being an adult
like cleaning your own toilets well you
know if you don't have a dorm room sorry
for people who don't have dorm rooms
because now I'm just taunting you
but this in-between space gives you for
the first time in your life time to pick
what you want to do so you can read
Foucault and talk about Foucault with
some of the smartest people you'll ever
meet and you can also skip a biology
test to drive to the Grand Canyon with a
girl you met the day before
don't let the freedom of that moment get
by you so that's my vote and one other
thing don't get too excited about the
fountainhead Hank I'll see you on Friday